to win this game he does have the white
pieces and he has made his first move or
can Magnus calls and get a draw or a win
to secure his spot in the semi-final
here we go here we go and a Sicilian
Defense so a different first move by
Levon aronian compared to two games ago
when he had white there he went for a
queen's Pawn opening now it's a
anti-sicilian and Magnus he's played
this move a few times now on the tour
pushing his Pawn forward in the center
it was very rare this last move up until
a couple of years ago and white decides
very quickly to Castle and this is
Black's idea just to control the center
to stop white pushing forward with any
pawns it looks a bit odd Black's
development the black dark Square Bishop
blocking a Central Pawn but seems
playable he's had success with this in
the past and Levon chooses not to try
anything too aggressive so you're just
pushing a pawn getting ready to develop
Magnus will get the king to safety he
needs to rush with that the Black Knight
will develop and Black's King will
Castle what do you think about this
opening choice
yeah I mean totally understandable um
when you when you only need a draw you
want to keep the position locked and you
can just see from what magdas has done
putting the pawns on dark squares
putting the bishop and dark Square he's
trying to lock it all up you know like I
said Lego you know get the Lego locked
in the middle so give your opponent Less
open lines to attack on
um I'm just saying that you do weaken a
square in the middle of the board by
putting your pawns on one card of
squares you weaken the opposite color
the light squares and with the last move
aronian is is probably going to try to
play this quite positional and just take
a big Square in the middle
um but so far all pretty normal I think
we can see yeah and they're more or less
following the game that uh Magnus played
with the black pieces against Fabiano
caruana in 2020 so I'm expecting this
bishop to step back towards the center
and then maybe Magnus will kick away the
other dark Square Bishop yeah so it's
always a matter of taste right
nights does white Retreat this bishop or
does white take the Black Knight What
would
van curse Simon what would you be
inclined to do I'd definitely be very
tempted to move it back but only because
I've got one plan and a position I can
see and that is take this middle square
that Middle Light Square so I just want
to put all my pieces okay this is also
quite interesting because you're going
to gain more control and here we go over
that middle square and the bishop now is
is controlling that one maybe of a
knight coming in and I think aronian's
whole game plan and attempt to get an
advantage will be based just on this
Square first of all then maybe he can
transfer that to another Advantage
um so I think it's sensible play from
from Lev as well at the moment yeah
sorry I was just going to say that this
is totally new position yeah it's a bit
odd because you mentioned if we just
backtrack again in this position you
mentioned the White's most common move
is to retreat the bishop I guess to this
square and then black normally gives
this bishop a nudge anyway so uh there
you could trade and then jump forward
with the Knight it feels like you've
gained a move uh black has lost time
pushing this Pawn
so just by trading off immediately
Magnus has the move castles instead of
this small in a simple move it doesn't
look like much doesn't look like a huge
difference but every move counts in
chess and uh slightly surprised that
aronian in this position captured the
Knight willingly normally you want to
wait but uh yeah if we catch up slightly
surprising decision as well that he
didn't choose to occupy the Central
Square with a knight
what are we thinking about that one
instead of putting the Knight on a
slightly more passive Square
yeah I mean the Knight is it's a normal
Square for like a royal Lopez Spanish
opening the Knight has a lot of
potential but it is certainly a slower
approach that erodians are aiming to
play here
um and I mean just looking at the pieces
White's pieces look very good the bishop
that Magnus has just moved is a pretty
terrible piece
um it might have hope later on but you
know you put a you have a bishop on the
same kind of square as your Pawns in the
middle it makes it a bad piece because
you're you're blocked in by those pawns
so I would I would say a slight
advantage to White here at the moment
but you've got to get a win and and
black is very solid uh hence why Magnus
has picked this variation yeah and uh
the one fear for me if I were 11 Iranian
or ironian's fans right now
um I remember him having this type of
opening it's not exactly the same but
this Pawn structure against Magnus in
the past he's lost a couple of games
from the white side when Magnus as black
has this Pawn structure so fun memories
for the Norwegian but for Iranian he
needs with a plan also this Pawn
structure makes it very difficult for
white to come up with a plan as we
mentioned the White Knight could have
maneuvered into the Central Square the
kind of square between these two pawns
that's a nice Outpost he chose not to do
that but what else do you do okay he
moves his Rook across is he just going
to reroute his Knight back and back and
back into the center but he could have
got there earlier I just don't really
understand and meanwhile black has quite
a common plan uh black at some point for
example we'll move the king out of the
way we'll move the queen out the way and
later we'll try to push some pawns on
this side of the board he can also push
pawns on this side Magnus has done this
before it's like his uh recipe for
success
just feels a bit strange what levon's
doing to me at least a bit slow the
winner of this quarterfinal match right
now looks like Magnus Carlsen if Lavon
does not win this game we'll meet the
winner of the Court final between
Vincent kymer and Prague nananda game
three has now ended with a draw and that
means Prague as well will be in a must
win situation in game four starting in
about 15 minutes to take that one to Ty
break any other result means kymer faces
or
Magnus in the semi-finals
that would be massive for Vincent Carmer
yeah definitely yeah he's qualified for
the quarterfinals before but I can
remember him losing too I want to sign
up on the ashy aha yeah the very first
tournament that we played that we had
yes
and uh Eric icy I don't think it's ever
been past the quarterfinals aha so if he
manages to get to Sammy's well we're
gonna see some new names in the semis
yeah yeah and I like David's prediction
there's going to be a teenager in the
final yeah I think I predicted as a
teenager would win it but I mean it was
a step too far but I mean it's quite
possible we might even see a fully
teenage final yeah if uh kaima or
pregnant or wins their semi-final and we
know at least one non-teenager will be
knocked out today either live on or
Magnus Carlson there's definitely
maximum gonna be two players who are not
teenagers in the semi-finals yeah and
Liam Lee he's in a fight for his life
against Neiman uh it's not gonna be easy
that one as well so yeah we could even
see three teenagers out of four in the
semi-finals yeah that would be
incredible we should of course mentioned
game four has started between Liam and
the Hans Neiman they are tied before
this game four so if you have a winner
in that game that player will be in the
semi-finals if it is a draw then tie
breaks and I can see the bar
slightly over to Liam's side in that
game four
yeah I'll take a quick look at oh he is
a pull-up very tense end game there
anything could happen still Eric I see
also looks like he's doing pretty well
but a lot of life left in that game too
yeah I mean it's hard to predict at this
point it just feels like every player
wants to beat the other one nobody's
playing safe even the drawers have been
full of fight
so do you think this is the most
entertaining tournament we've seen so
far in the tour most drama-ish that's
for sure like you know there's been
loads of stuff going on isn't there you
know just behind the scenes on the board
I mean you know we've got off the board
on the everywhere yeah I mean just uh
rumors and
yeah it's been has been a lot happening
so he's saying there's going to be a lot
happening in the you know I think the
next week or two as well and no matter
what happens in a tournament I was uh
trying to summarize how the
preliminaries went and there was just so
many exciting things you know there was
like Evan Turk you know it looked like
he was going to qualify at the beginning
and it was a big race oh my God it's
like a movie it was great to see a vein
chick have that brilliant day on day one
where he should have actually got uh
four out of four and that was just good
to see a legend fulfill that legendary
status again even though he's quite
Rusty compared to some of his younger
players and that was that was kind of a
bit of a highlight I think for me you
know um but we've got plenty more drama
to come David as well yeah so yeah I
mean this is called the generation cup
and it does feel like the packaging I
didn't realize that but yeah just
reminding you again yeah cheers I mean
it does feel like the changing of the
god which has been happening already for
the last few years it feels like this is
kind of the moment where it's we stop we
can just confirm that all these top
players all these young players I mean
they're part of the elite now and uh
they're here to stay and it's been a
nice breakthrough event for a couple of
them Christopher you for example yeah
yeah it's just uh yeah I think I'm
running out of uh adjectives
superlatives running out of praise for
them they're just so good and I have a
question about Christopher
um
it's cool good question 15 years old is
he a full-time chess professional or
good question you see he plays a lot I
was called maybe I studies a lot but I
know a lot of a lot of Chess
professionals are homeschooled because
it gives more flexibility to to you know
play in events like this and other
events as well potentially uh but I
don't know yeah so it's it's difficult
isn't it when you're around this age
because dedicating yourself to chess you
know it is a gamble you know because
there is only a certain amount of prize
pool and you have to kind of give up
other things but then if you dedicate
yourself to school it's a gamble because
you need to work in your chest so these
youngsters have to make that decision at
some stage you know do they give
everything to chess or do they uh do
they go the more academic route
um I spent day well David I mean you
were a prodigy and you did the
University route as well um so you can't
you can do both
um but yeah yeah I mean it's it's mixed
feelings for me I mean I look back and I
think oh I could have saved the three
four years I was at University just
to play chess I could have been better I
could have soaked up more while I was
younger but at the same time I wanted to
keep my options open I I mean I had the
best years of my life at universities so
um you know it's it's you have to
sacrifice something I guess you can't
have it all but a lot of the top players
I mean we we saw Prague a few months ago
playing in a final doing his exams side
by side simultaneously within the same
day and he can do it so yeah nowadays I
guess also even if they commit to Chess
at a young age there's options later
career-wise other things they could
Branch into using the chests maybe as a
as a kind of launching pad yeah but uh
yeah meanwhile back in this game still
very stable
right now just creating some pressure on
this left side of the board but it's so
tense in the center yeah we're still
waiting for that pawn breakthrough or
the kind of the right Maneuvers to occur
and whilst the tension builds in this
position
um we do have a question from Spruce who
asks us how would you guys rate this
tournament in terms of the play
for me it seems like one of the highest
level and most entertaining rapid
tournaments I've ever seen so some nice
words from Spruce but
tell us what you think of the play has
it been fighting I think it's been
incredibly high standard for a start I
mean you know let's remember this it's
rapid so it's not long play where you
have loads of time to calculate
everything but I I feel that the stand
has been just it probably the best I've
seen you know it hasn't been many
blunders there's been great conversions
of advantages it's had everything really
I mean uh David I mean would you go
along with that as well I agree yeah I
mean there are games in the prelims that
have ventric against Carlson game just
for me that was just the Highlight just
both players throwing everything at each
other tactics Galore I mean incredibly
high level yes occasionally there's a
blunder in some of the games we've seen
but I mean it's that happens like you
said in Rapid and
yeah yeah I mean uh also there were no
kind of clear underdogs so everyone was
packed in the middle everyone was
beating everyone
's so ambitious in every game and that's
what we love to see I love boring
drawers no quick draws perfect draws at
all right no I know quick draws which is
great because I know some of the other
events we've had there's been a bit of
criticism about uh people having quick
draws and uh that's that seems to have
stopped so they've got the right players
in I think and I mean I'd love to ask
people on Twitter that's where we're
looking at a lot of our you know
questions you might even get your Tweet
up on the screen uh what other players
would be quite interesting to have in
you know is there anyone else that we
you know people think we're missing
maybe I don't think we can really beat
the the current mix but um you know I
thought this tournament was the perfect
combination you know it had Legends of
the game it had a youth and of course
you have the people who are at the top
of their careers and it was fresh just
to see everyone fight and I have to say
I agree with Simon some of the most
entertaining chess came from the old
Legend Russell evanchook himself but
it's been fun and mouthwash Champion's
chest or each tournament has a little
bit of a theme I remember last season we
had the FDX crypto cup which was the
highest rated tournament ever
I mean most of the top 10 players in the
world participated in that that's always
fun as well
[Music]
that was the one where Magnus really
struggled right
he eventually uh won it didn't he after
that yeah that was that insane final
against Wesley so wasn't it but he
barely got out of the prelims yeah I
think maybe the only time he struggled
to get out of the prelims Fabiano
caruana won the prelims in that one yes
he did and I remember that Magnus was in
a must-win situation to qualify to The
Knockouts he had to beat rageable
and he didn't and he did yeah he was so
Indian I remember Quincy too
[Music]
no I don't remember that far long time
ago well actually not that long ago but
uh yeah it feels like every tournament
has a different energy as well sometimes
it's really tense you can tell the
players are really nervous this event
everyone's just let loose and uh that's
why we've been so entertained meanwhile
that was a critical moments the Rooks
came off on the a file and there was a
Trader Brooks and Black's Bishop went
into the corner to recapture and I think
that was actually a good move Black's
remaining Rook uh is needed to defend
his King because suddenly the white
Knights and the white lights go at
Bishop they're kind of pointing towards
uh the black king the black Monarch I
like what white the aronians done over
the last couple of movies because we're
talking about uh the placement of Pawns
and to try to work out a plan if you
look at the placement of Pawns around
Black's King they're all on light
squares so what does that mean it makes
the opposite color squares weak the dark
squares and you can see with Lev's last
move uh Lev's trying to get in on those
dark squares control those dark squares
combined with the Knight as well so
there's a lot of pieces near magnus's
King you know I'd be a little bit scared
if I was black here and this last moves
are very very nice move he might be
going for a bit of counter Play Now by
getting ready to move the pawn in front
of his Rook which you pointed out
earlier David is a very standard idea
open up the Bishops and get some
attacking chances yourself
yeah but then again I would be slightly
scared of White's pieces gravitating
towards that black king still for
example
you mentioned pieces of flooding in
maybe the queen could come in and uh
maybe for example if black is a bit too
slow say
actually it's hard to say it's hard to
find a move here that's slow uh the
Knight is under attack this Pawn is also
Under Fire so say black pushes yeah it
just feels like somehow on this light
Square diagonal very loose very weak
Knight's jumping in but maybe no threat
maybe that's the issue and maybe black
can break out in another way maybe black
has this bone push as well we talked
about Pawn structures in the last game
but here it's Kaya's favorite the Mean
Girls Connect Four and they block out
the whole white Army if the position
opens up like you said these pieces come
to life
yeah it's it's hard to say really I mean
there's so many different plans you
could even push this Pawn forward I
really beautiful well of course that
that was on the radar so uh funnily
enough it's always on the radar I mean
how dare you doubt that pushing Harry's
not on the radar
when he wakes up hello and when I go to
bed the first and last thing in my life
Harry come on my friend just push
yourself to the limits and I'm also
wondering if the white Rook I mean it's
doing a good job in the center just in
case things open up but I'm wondering if
it ever comes this way probably not
right now because uh anything any
squares it uses along this a file
they're not gonna actually threaten that
much they'll be easily kicked out later
on
uh what else could white try
hard to say I mean this
so many candidate moves the one thing I
would be slightly worried about is uh if
I were Iranian is this bishop it looks
fantastic right now but later if black
can somehow push upon push another Pawn
this Bishop's actually running out of
squares
but then again
a couple of ifs and that's a far bit in
the future looks like we've got some
quite big news I mean just to keep an
eye on some of the other games that are
going on the the big one I I would say
is between Liam Lacon and Neiman yep
um and it seems that uh Liam Lee's is is
rolling in that game and and very close
to winning at the moment which would
mean Neiman would be removed from the
competition if uh he loses that one so
there's tense moments there as well it
is game four they are tied before this
game bar all the way over to Liam's side
is he winning that game simply yes okay
white has a pawn uh on the seventh rank
so one move away from promoting to a new
Queen and Black's whole Army is tied
down defending uh so Neiman on the back
foot really struggling
I think it's a miracle if any man
survives that game okay obviously we
have not been able to get a comment from
Hans name on this whole tournament with
all the drama going on with Magnus
Carlsen we will of course try today as
well it would be really nice to hear
from him before he uh leaves the
tournament if he loses this game
so he left getting serious there he's
stripping off he's getting excited I
think he's he's got a tactic
well on the board he's got a trick up
his sleeve he does look at those white
Knights they do look very scary it
wouldn't be surprising if there was a
tactic I don't know how effective it is
though but uh the sneaky trick that I
saw was that uh say black plays uh
just a non-move or something oh okay say
a non-move Let's uh bring the bishop
yeah and then you know you could put
your knight on the H6 Square nice uh I
don't know whether it does anything
because
it's attacking this Square twice uh
three times and the trick is after Queen
takes Knight Knight Knight takes Pawn is
a fork not just because the Knight hits
the king and the queen but even if the
Knight is removed the White Queen has
opened up an attack against the black
queen and white would have won a queen
for two pieces in the process that's
actually a really nice trick really
important threat actually Ivanka so this
might be a threat in the position
uh my first instinct was what to do if
the pawn pushes forward to kick away
this night this night has just landed in
the black half of the board and when a
piece lands in my half I always want to
kick it out
and uh
he can't Retreat right Levon won't a
true Retreat well that's why I was
wondering as well David because it looks
so obvious to play that move and uh but
is there any way you can avoid
retreating the night I mean you don't
you really don't want to move that
Knight backwards as you said David but
what else can you do I take
Foreigner two of my favorite things you
know Harry the swinger yeah and suddenly
I mean due to the fact that this bishop
is actually just like a laser beam
cutting across the board on this
diagonal Black's King Black's Queen I
didn't really see how to save them
that's a beautiful idea isn't it I mean
I mean yeah really process of
elimination oh wow Magnus Carlson and
he's in he plays he sacrifices the
streets without thinking Levon he's
going to give his Queen up somehow oh
man I think yeah yeah he loves giving up
his Queen foot of rook and a piece or
even more material but right now it
looks like that Queen is doomed it's
gonna get hit it's going to get pinned
by the white rook and there we go it's
chaos reigning again so of course you
only need a draw to stay in the
competition what you do is Magnus you
sat your queen
crazy yeah sensible idea there Magnus as
far as uh definitely moving up for Levon
aronian is this giving him some good
winning chances
definitely wow I mean maybe losing
chances as well but you don't care about
that a draw is the same as a loss now
for Iranian brilliant play I have to say
brilliant idea that night move I mean
just really aggressive and this is how
you beat Magnus yeah you I rarely see
Magnus losing unless someone attacks him
and there we go we've got this very
strange position the White Queen comes
in what's the material situation here
David yeah we can do a quick count white
has a queen and a pawn in return black
has a rook Knight and Bishop so if we do
some maths Queen and pawn is 10 Rook
Knight and Bishop that's 11 I think so
black is technically one point up but
the black king is so open computer
thinks there's only one move for black
in that last position and Magnus found
it who would you take your bank here
would you take um Lev's position or
magnus's position I would take magnus's
position I'm afraid to say you know
because levonne isn't a must-win
situation and uh look at what Magnus is
doing is just simply over protecting
every single one of his pieces and pawns
but uh okay Levon has his chances I live
on has to disrupt blacks Harmony now I
mean I'm thinking maybe Harry step
forward it must be time to put him in
the position surely the White Queen
needs back up you need to open up the
black king and black king only has one
Pawn shelter yeah it makes sense to push
the White H Pawn up
trade off that last Defender and uh one
thing I will note Levon aronian he's on
record in interviews saying he hates in
speeches he hates playing uh with the
queen against pieces he thinks it's
easier to play with pieces because
there's more of them a queen alone it
feels like you have one piece fighting
against three so black having a rook
Knight and Bishop for that Queen
significant later if they're both down
to one minute it's far harder to play
with the queen than the three pieces if
they're stable if they're not just
dropping off those pieces he's Gotta
Throw Harry okay well he's got he's gone
for more exchanges now and um he hasn't
got many pieces left but he's got an
idea of an currency behind us move so
yeah it is kind of a disrupter move you
know his whole idea is that the bishop
takes the bishop well then it releases
the protection of the Pawn on D7 and
maybe the queen can even swoop in and
take that pawn
look at this the queen she's fighting a
war on her own against four pieces but
maybe she's winning that War uh look at
these pieces how do they defend each
other maybe they don't
first this bishop is doomed it's going
to drop off the board
maybe this bishop will drop off then
maybe the Knight Will
want to move by 11 Iranian that was not
on my radar I couldn't met Bishop in to
get rid of this Defender
and uh what else could live on Iranian
try
if this bishop drops if then suddenly
the light squares are all are for grabs
all that white needs is to get his Queen
in for example that last variation if
you can get your queen in you might be
winning
I mean I'm I'm still not sure maybe
Black's better here the computer always
think but to me from a human point of
view it looks scary it does is there any
chance that black could kind of like
bear in mind that he's in a draw
situation just curl up in a ball with
his pieces and so I was thinking say
after Bishop takes Bishop in the game so
the game continued with C4
Pawn takes and then he jumps in now yeah
then you just gotta go I know it's ugly
but I'm going to do it but move my Rook
to the f
six square and yeah I have a feeling
magnus's idea actually with uh this
previous Pawn push is to even plant his
bishop and start attacking uh Magnus
wants to go on the attack against whites
pawns now White's King
and uh okay we have seen that Bishop
trade
and what will love on Iranian do maybe
he'll try and prevent this bishop
coming to this Square I don't really see
how
it's very nearly a move in the center
like D4 isn't there just trying to
liberate your pawns a little bit here I
think it's a bit too risky here but this
is the kind of move where you know it's
on the radar because when you're playing
we've seen this in other days with the
queen against the minor pieces so when
the queen is facing all these other guys
it's about discombobulating those pieces
meaning you've got to make them not
harmonize very well you've got to try to
spread them apart make sure they can't
defend each other and a move like this
would be maybe very interesting because
you've got to check as well if it's
captured but maybe it doesn't quite work
you know the concept here but that's
certainly the kind of thing I think you
should be looking for to do in in a
position like this discombobulate your
opponent's pieces my favorite word a bit
of discombobulation I love it doesn't it
sound nice yeah
discombobulate yeah yeah that's it yeah
discombobulated did you pick up that
word Simon it's not one that you kind of
like Chuck around and every day I think
it's the first word I ever said when I
was like two I was like two days old two
days off did this come populate I'm
gonna discombobulate the world
so uh yeah I don't know but it sounds
like it should sound though like
onomatopoeia is that right David you're
the English okay I don't know
maybe that's too complicated for me
Simon what sure let's stick to his
explain okay do you have a favorite word
though you want like you know chess any
word anyways good not really it's just
chocolate
I think that came to my mind that's not
a bad word yeah
okay well back to the game and you know
um he's moved his King so he can move
the pawn in front of his King if needed
does uh does eroding yeah but it doesn't
look like the type of move that will
discombobulate Magnus this last king
move white king is yeah okay a slightly
better placed it's not on a dark Square
uh as you mentioned so it can't get
targeted by Black's Bishop but love on a
ronin right now he's just deciding what
pawn structure he wants either he will
just recapture this black pawn in the
center or he'll maybe give a check first
with the White Queen you can drop back
just diagonally wants to go check the
black king and then go across and take
this Pawn with your queen as well
okay he just takes back the simple
approach but now this white Pawn that's
just moved it's a backward Pawn it's
it's a bit ugly it could be a target for
blacks pieces later
I mean you're not going to win this game
just with your queen are you this this
is the important thing that aronium
realizes he he can't do everything with
one piece he can do a lot but he needs
to do something else so naturally what
else can you use your pawns come on
Harry just move yourself my friend he's
got to use his pawns right I mean and
there it goes yeah I mean it was pretty
pretty obvious that was going to come
next uh Simon asks and Levon delivers ah
so what will I see Lev so and natural
move though just trying to move that
forwards again uh but magnus's pieces
seem to be pretty okay right at the
moment I don't think he's in too much
danger as of yet and uh we have a result
you guys Liam Lee is the winner of the
quarterfinal match against Hans Neiman
winning game for that means Hans Neiman
is knocked out there will not be a final
in this tournament between Hans Neiman
and Magnus Carlson
the Liam he goes through to the
semi-final to face the winner of um the
quartz final between Eric icy and
Christopher you they have played the
game three other guys he is in the lead
and that match will be decided in game
four or and let's try breaks if
Christopher you wins
all right so it's over for Neiman
after what has been a turbulent
tournament do you think he's tired now
yomenko
probably I would say you know he's been
on an emotional roller coaster I I can
say and you know his games have been
very up and down you know it's difficult
to play chess when you're when there's
kind of lacking inconsistency and also
you know he's playing very well or not
so well and of course the drama and the
public scrutiny around him must be just
intense
yeah I mean he's done very well in the
circumstances we've uh we've got to tip
our hats to him yeah but difficult day
today and Liam is a classy player rapid
specialist as we know uh who's played
very well on the tour so Liam in the
semi-finals yeah
he is in fourth place on the tour
standings overall Liam yes we know he is
extremely good in this online rapid
format and could even take third place
if Prague is knocked out today Prague is
in third place Duda second place and
Magnus in first place overall in the
mouth of the Champions Chester 2022. we
do have a bunch of moves here what's
happening yeah we see a bunch of moves
and some pawns have disappeared from the
board Levon of running has just won
another Pawn in that little process so
right now the material balance is Queen
and three Pawns for blacks pieces black
sponge or pieces The Rook Knight and
Bishop so Magnus is just he's got a
small objective material advantage but
the black pieces they're coming to life
those black pieces I love that black
Bishop I've got to say it's there
forever now it's gonna defend it's gonna
attack yeah this looks pretty safe for
Magnus I mean uh I'm thinking if black
doesn't do anything now because we
talked about those pieces defending each
other every single black piece is
defended by something else now so he's
got full coordination and how does white
do anything here he can't use his Queen
he's got to use his pawns how can it so
therefore he needs to break through of
his pawns and there's not too many Pawn
breaks that are going to achieve
anything at all so it looks at the
moment even though it's a weird position
it looks like Magnus is doing abs is
doing very well very likely to go
through a draw a draw at least here I
think there's still some danger though
for Magnus you know because I I don't
think it's going to be that easy for him
you know just to curl up into a little
ball he has to be alert because those
pawns are going to do some damage like
for instance that Bishop in the middle
it looks like it's anchored but it's not
entirely safe it can be destabilized by
a pawn a potential Pawn push on the F
line
it's true yeah and you know we see that
Lev's Now using a pawn to try and cause
a little bit of uh disharmony but now
Magnus has just got this you know such a
solid position I mean how do you how do
you break through here it's really not
going to be not going to be easy but I
mean one thing I
it's not going to be easy somehow I
wanted to magically transport the king
over to the right side of the board it's
not going to get there though let's say
I move my rope backwards and forwards
forever I think you have to push your
your Gary or Harry Pawn don't you and
this move actually this is probably just
a class move holding up White's pawns
from advancing even more now
um I'm a little bit sad that Hans has
gone from taunt I'll be you know because
we've had so much I say fun I mean I
don't know if drama is the right word
and you know and it's been it's been a
real roller coaster isn't it the whole
event so and like you said he's for a
young kid had so much pressure put on
him it's uh intense but yeah I mean just
on this position I just wanted to say
these two pawns are frozen they can
nearly never move forward that means
these two are left and as Simon says the
knight uh can easily deal with them
I think it's almost a guarantee at this
point if Magnus does nothing wrong he's
through to the semis yeah he could make
it through in this game Magnus Carlsen
Liam is the first player ready for
semi-finals rejoined by Liam
congratulations
hi guys thank you very much so how did
you experience today's Court final match
against Hans Neiman
it was a very interesting match
perhaps I could have finished it a bit
earlier because I was completely winning
in game two
um but there were some tactics I
couldn't see this when he played Knight
D7 I had a feeling I was winning but um
I did not say this FG and Bishop E4 so
that was a big Miss right there and then
I think in game one and game three and
also this last game I played very decent
chance yeah fantastic and uh playing
Hans Neiman of course there's a lot of
talk in the Chess World these days I bet
you've heard as well some people
suspecting him of cheating Magnus
Carlsen
um probably one of those people were you
uncomfortable playing hunts today
no I I just
just as a normal game um
regarding the Magnus hands situation I
don't have um I'm in the middle I don't
have a clear opinion because
I feel like we are not given enough
information so I don't know what to
think I'm just waiting for more
information more evidence to come up if
there's any So based on his games in the
single cup and in this tournament I I
don't think he he cheated so I mean I I
just feel very normal and I just try to
focus on chess and not saying too much
about the other stuff yeah I appreciate
your comment on that to Liam and
tomorrow in semi-finals you're
definitely gonna face another teenager
either Eric icy or Christopher you a 15
year old what is it like playing these
youngsters
yeah they are both extremely talented
and I lost both of them in the
preliminaries so
um either way I will try to get my
revenge but um I think for now
adren is the player favorite
um but yeah anything can happen actually
what's the score now
the score is that Eric icy is in the
lead winning game three so game four
starts in a few minutes I think so
um you will have to win that game
okay yeah
so that's going to be interesting we'll
pay attention to that as well and Liam
best of luck in uh semifinals tomorrow
thank you for joining us thank you
see you tomorrow
he is ready for the semi-finals will he
be joined by Magnus Carlsen or will we
see uh tie breaks between himself and
Lavon can Lavon win this game or is all
hope out
it's it's fading I would say uh just
look how solid Black's position is black
has so many Defenders around his King
Levon now has committed one of his pawns
he's just gambling that one of his Pawn
pushers is going to work but Magnus can
just Retreat this Rook
I don't really see what's next
I think if Magnus literally doesn't do
anything then um there's nothing white
can do I mean maybe he can move his King
backwards and forwards
um you've got to try to push Harry I
guess to to do a break so I think Lev's
trying to bring his Queen around to
to do that but then yeah then the Night
comes in I can't see anything I think
this is I think he's just got a actually
has a fortress here and uh it's gonna be
a Droid can't see it anyway at all white
white can break through yeah that and uh
Magnus maybe even could be more
ambitious if he wanted to be but he's
happy to just curl up sit there and I
know he doesn't believe in fortresses
but this one looks very sturdy very
strong friendship gave him a good lesson
on the fortresses
I think he started believing in them
yeah he should he should believe after
after facing Evancho because look Levon
shaking his head there he knows that
he's running out of steam he's running
out of ideas the white king is tied down
two white pawns are frozen
yeah Magnus is done too good you know
there was a little bit of danger for
black and Magnus had just found the way
to neutralize all that and now he just
has just impenetrable Fortress and now
the Rook zooms up to a protected Square
this is very nice technique
um
oh and here comes a pawn break but here
comes Harry yeah yeah it's not I mean I
don't know what white does next you know
I mean this this was the only thing that
white could try but so what what what's
next the Black Knight is a fantastic
Defender uh and the white king where's
it going it's not really going anywhere
it can't do anything uh and you know
um I still don't see absolutely anyway
at all that white can create any threats
uh that last move is quite interesting
because he's he's given up the H Pawn he
didn't need to do this but once the
Black Knight to get in I think Magnus is
actually playing for the win yeah I
think a draw will be enough he'll take a
draw if it comes but if the Black Knight
gets in if you could pick it up and put
it on the F4 Square first of all that
would be a fork right now but in general
if you could put it on that square it's
great attacking great defensive piece
that's the only piece that can be
improved the Black Knight
and uh yeah I would be terrified
if this was just a one-off game and
there was no match there was no kind of
need to draw need to win I would be
terrified of losing this one as white to
be honest yeah Rook Knight and Bishop
it's like you said earlier you need to
discombobulate them but they're all on
their perfect squares they're all kind
of perfectly defended
this is a problem of playing these world
champions they they kind of know where
to put their pieces don't they they're
kind of good aren't they really unfair
isn't it you know it's like well no not
again yeah you know so yeah I have a
question for you both have you seen the
Ted lasso show oh yeah great show great
okay have you have you seen it no but I
heard about it okay I haven't seen it
either what is that I don't know about
an american guy who comes over to manage
a football team in the UK oh he's like a
fish out of water yes okay okay
yeah because I'm just going to read out
a tweet and because I haven't seen the
show I'm gonna rely on David's judgment
it says LOL Keck says with the best
possible sentiment
Simon reminds me so much of Coach beard
in Ted lasso I'm not sure
I'm not sure I like where this is going
do we have a do we have a picture of
Coach beard I don't know can we I like
his name Brandon oh what's it coach
really yeah
celebrity I I didn't think there was
anyone who'd like no I've never had that
before maybe this guy from uh
Christopher what a guy from Game of
Thrones but I don't look oh yeah
which is awesome because he's he's
called oh yeah he's really cool but I
can't I've got to see this picture now
yeah thanks yeah brilliant yeah that's
really nice but it's the characters the
characters he's a funny guy he's he's
very witty comes in at the right moments
he looks like a guy that after a
football game would comment with a sign
you resign now yeah just just resign
yeah yeah I highly recommend the show I
I cried many times during this oh no oh
is that emotional I'm gonna have to
watch this yeah okay comedy can be
emotional guys
I know my life
[Laughter]
[Music]
I mean this is there's nothing going on
here is that I mean there's the there's
literally no way white can create a fret
this is the problem you can't create
fret just with your queen and porn the
white King's not getting in it's it's
yeah and as you mentioned David if black
was really trying to win this game he he
could start moving forwards but that
would compromise his defense a little
bit so there's no need to move forwards
um in this position so I think uh yeah
they they could be shaking hands well
shaking mouses or whatever they do and
shuffling their mouses virtual Hi-Fi I'm
not sure yeah yeah and just to show I
mean we could get a result any moment I
think live on Iranian will give up his
winning chances just to show okay he
goes back with his King the one possible
winning attempt uh some of the viewers
at home might be asking why not push a
pawn but first of all there's no threat
this Pawn is not actually going anywhere
the Black Knight the rhyme goes Knight
on f8 there is no mate so the White
Queen can't even use this Square for
example the Black Knight covers
everything but the black root just drops
back this Pawn drops off
game over uh so I mean I say game over
at least winning chances are gone the
Black Knight will take this pawn and uh
as we mentioned for example in a
situation like this
um okay the the Knight might take but
the knight's just going to come out it's
going to plonk itself on this beautiful
F4 Outpost and actually the white king
is going to get checkmated it's not the
black king that's in danger
um if we go back to the game if white
can't push this Pawn forward then what
else uh Magnus he's happy to move his
King the queen gives a check and again
if the pull steps forward it just gets
pinned and it drops off the board
now you're essentially just playing with
your queen alone if you can't push that
pawn
no plan no plan that's the theme of The
Day plans versus no plans and
just like we saw in some of the other
games if one side doesn't have a plan
there's no hope no chance of winning
and there we have Basha watching the
show and cheering for Liam Lee yeah all
the way in Hanoi Vietnam staying up all
night I really appreciate everyone who's
been watching the show and uh meanwhile
in the game Lavon has tried to make a
winning attempt he's given up the F3
Pawn you can see why he's done he
grabbed the horn but this looks bad oh
no he's gonna lose his Queen and he's
smiling about it and it's that's a good
way to lose just smile and resign yeah
he knows it draws the same as a loss
unfortunately wherever you put the white
king after a couple of tracks the black
Rook will win the White Queen just a
couple of simple checks eventually The
Rook will go th file take that piece off
the board so I think he has resigned
yeah
it's over level neuronian is knocked out
of the Julius bird generation cup after
a very nice and entertaining fight
Magnus Carlsen he makes it through to
another semi-final